Our treatment of matchings
wouldn't be complete,
without talking about the notion
of a perfect matching.
Consider a bipartite graph, G,
where the size of the left and
the right hand side are equal.
Then we say that a matching is perfect,
if it has the same
cardinality as the two sides.
Another way of saying this is to
say that all vertices are matched.
To review some of the key
concepts from the lesson so
far we'll do a short exercise.
Assume the left and right hand sides are
of the same size and then the question
is which of the following imply
that there is a perfect matching.
The fact that for
all subsets of the right hand side.
The neighborhood of that set is at
least the size of the set itself.
How about the fact that there
is a vertex cover of size L?
Or the fact that there is a matching
M that admits an alternating
Hamiltonian cycle.